[SPEAKER_03]: Tyrus, you're out there standing, and basically Gouge has gone for about 20 minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then you see the shape of Gouge, and obviously Folsom, walking back, talking quietly to one another.
[SPEAKER_02]: The streets have kind of thinned out.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's approaching 10.
[SPEAKER_02]: 10 p.m., and the merchants, even though you can see them far off in the distance, they don't come down this far, really.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's a dark dock.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see the two of them walk towards you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just the two of them?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I see them, too, because I'm on the deck?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I see him up on the deck?
[SPEAKER_03]: He's on the dock, and he's on the deck.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you see him on the deck?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm walking, I'm going like this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge just motions them down.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll start walking towards you guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where's the deck?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna follow Ty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, so if you want to, you can message or you can just have a conversation with them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna have a conversation with both of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: When they get there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we're walking towards them.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got this, I'll make it short and sweet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Owen sent the guys to kill us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tried to capture him.
[SPEAKER_03]: He got away.
[SPEAKER_03]: We either take the ship and get out right now, or if we think Owen doesn't have people here to protect him, we can go try to take him.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what we've got to figure out right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Owen sent the guys to get us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, so this is what we need to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Either get the hell out of here with that ship right now because we're not safe here and we're all beat down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or nobody gives a shit about him, which I'm kind of thinking is more like it here, but this is a decision we all need to make and we need to stick together because we're all... Why would Owen double-cross us like that?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's not what I'm worried about right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: We gotta make a decision to stay or go.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm saying stay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go be discreet though, hide.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's your feeling?
[SPEAKER_03]: You were with him and went through that, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: He only had one guy on the ship, plus the guys that he, I forgot to tell you this, while we were walking, he handed a pouch of gold coins to a man and said, I owed him a debt, and I could tell that he was lying to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's right, because it was silver coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I didn't know why.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's because he was paying them to take us out.
[SPEAKER_01]: And why would he take us out unless there's something else here?
[SPEAKER_03]: They were going to take him to King Tolley.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cain.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tolley.
[SPEAKER_03]: King Tolley.
[SPEAKER_03]: They were going to take you to King Tolley?
[SPEAKER_03]: They were trying to prison me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, it's not King Tolley this whole time.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's Cain.
[SPEAKER_03]: To Cain Tolley.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cain.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is no King Tolley.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cain Tolley.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cain.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why?
[SPEAKER_02]: Now do an int check.
[SPEAKER_02]: What were they asking you about?
[SPEAKER_02]: What did Owen tell his buddy that you knew?
[SPEAKER_02]: They were really pressing me on the artifact.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is after they captured you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, after they captured me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen told his friend he wants to know about the artifact.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you know about the artifact that Owen didn't know?
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen told me everything he knew.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which was, what artifact?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you don't know?
[SPEAKER_00]: You were sleeping.
[SPEAKER_01]: What the fuck is going on here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's go find a discreet place that we can talk about.
[SPEAKER_04]: I understand, but that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, we don't have to go through that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to stay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I want to find out what the fuck the deal is.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys want to stay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we should stay because if Owen bribed just some random guy on the street,
[SPEAKER_00]: To fight you guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: He has no one else backing him up, just that one guy on the ship that he brought me on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, otherwise he'd have his own men do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or there'd be way more men on that ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go find that ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: What kind of ship was it?
[SPEAKER_00]: A sloop just like this one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: He said it was for Tyrus as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think we should... Are we staying?
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess we're staying.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, we get out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a battle at high seas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could be a battle at high seas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we're not very fast.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if we got dragons walking all the way, yeah, just stay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Stay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, then we better go hole up somewhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, let's go get anything from the ship you guys need.
[SPEAKER_03]: I gotta make sure I got my backpack and stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, this was Owen's ship?
[SPEAKER_02]: The sloop is Owen's ship, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a crater that black we're on.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's food, too.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I want to go through his quarters.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did he have his own private quarters?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had things in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: It wasn't like he was keeping you guys out of anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait a minute.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe we should dispose of those dead bodies, turn the lights out and hole up in the ship and wait them to come back, thinking the deed was done.
[SPEAKER_04]: Himx comes back and sees all of his men that he hired dead.
[SPEAKER_03]: The guys that ran off?
[SPEAKER_03]: Hide the dead bodies.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_03]: And stow away on his ship with the lights off, let him come back and jump him thinking that
[SPEAKER_01]: We shouldn't be on the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should watch the ship, if anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: If there's more people, they're going to know where to find us.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're going to check the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: We want to look for a place that is as close to the ship as we can be.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's get rid of those bodies by the bar, so they're not just stacked up here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's drag them off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so we go back to the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five minute walk back to the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the question is... Do we want to go back to that area?
[SPEAKER_02]: We want to go back to the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two of those guys, you let go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three of those guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two of those guys, you let go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three of those guys got away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three other ones got away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the two I let go, what difference does that make?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they know what happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the other three ran.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they going to report back to Owen?
[SPEAKER_00]: They weren't hired by Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were hired by the guy that's dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no way Owen's gonna know about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: The bartender will.
[SPEAKER_01]: The bartender will know it all.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anybody that was in the bar will know it all.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not really a bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's more of a short room.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not worried about him knowing.
[SPEAKER_01]: He knows that we're still alive if that's the case.
[SPEAKER_01]: What he doesn't know is where we're at.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to hole up where we can watch the ship if there's someone... Is there an emergent tent we could go in and pay off to stay in there for a little bit?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, there are other options.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys can walk up the island off the beach and up onto... Land.
[SPEAKER_02]: Land.
[SPEAKER_01]: Higher up on land.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually just sit in the...
[SPEAKER_01]: So nobody knows we're there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Up in the bushes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: You pay somebody off.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or you could find a...
[SPEAKER_02]: An N to stay in.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you want to just be there watching the boat, you guys can go up into that area.
[SPEAKER_03]: Take the food.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're always used to living in the woods here, so that's not a problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got enough supplies for
[SPEAKER_01]: At least a couple days.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is still coastline, so I have expertise here.
[SPEAKER_04]: This whole aisle went.
[SPEAKER_04]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've got expertise.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I wouldn't mind getting overnighters.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's grab some stores and head up and I temper it so we don't need a fire.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not going to freeze to death.
[SPEAKER_03]: Start bandaging some wounds and take watch.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll go in two and twos.
[SPEAKER_03]: Light the lanterns on the boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: On the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm going to get, I'm going to use my... What if we just undock the ship and just let it go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Then we're stranded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then we have no ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's get someplace set, sit there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to use my... Yeah, good call on the land.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's going to make it a lot easier to see someone approaching it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to use my lay on hands.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to use all of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, you guys walk up into the hill overlooking the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: With provisions.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you take that crate of black rum and food, or what do you take?
[SPEAKER_03]: We're gonna take the food.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll take a couple bottles, and I ain't sharing, so grab your own if you want it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't need it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you walk up and sit on the hill.
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume that you basically try and hide your party?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Using the skills?
[SPEAKER_03]: Shadows, me, said, I'll stay up watching.
[SPEAKER_03]: Folsom, you stay up.
[SPEAKER_03]: You two rest if you need to recover.
[SPEAKER_03]: I do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: So.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I get a fighter lay on hand thing he was talking about, or first level, or no?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you get what's called second wind, which is you can use the bonus actions to roll one die ten and get that many hit points, plus your level back in fighter.
[SPEAKER_02]: It might be just your level.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you roll a 1-9-10 and you can get back up to 16 points.
[SPEAKER_03]: So he can do that now?
[SPEAKER_03]: He can do that whenever.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you can do that now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'll do that now because it's every short rest, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can do that now.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys are going to take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's do all of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are up in the hill, overlooking the bay, watching what's happening.